How are you making fruit jams that aren't full of sugar? Do you have a good sugar-free or low sugar recipe?
You can if you get the shurjale, which I do use shurjale, I know there's recipes to make jams without the pectin,
but I use pectin in my fruit jams that I make. You can make the low sugar
portion in the shurjale recipe. They do have a recipe for that. Personally, I don't do the low sugar.
You just don't eat a lot of jams. I mean, you're only putting a tablespoon of jams on your
bread or whatever you use it. Of course, you're not like you're eating the whole jar full of jams,
so I'm not that concerned about that. I love making jams. That's one of my favorite things to
make. I make blueberry jam, raspberry jam, strawberry jam. This summer I found wild grapes at our
office, which was a really fun find. I'd used them. We had a gallon of grape juice, and I thought,
well, we don't have grape juice. I thought, I'm going to make jam out of it. So I made grape jelly,
out of it. It was really fun. So it's first time I ever made grape jelly. We give our jamb away,
our kids and our grandkids are who eat most of our jams. So something I just like making. I like
doing it. It's something I really enjoy doing is kidding. So I know it's weird for a guy to like
to do that, but I really like to do kidding. Hot water bath and pressure kidding, pressure can
a lot of meat. When we lived it, we used to live up in the woods, 280 acres, and we were off grid.
So we didn't have really refrigeration options. We had a fairly small propane refrigerator with a
little TDW freezer. So freezing meat just wasn't an option. We only had a few solar panels. So
then we had propane lights. So we used mainly caracene lamps in our house. So we didn't have
refrigeration. So we had to learn how to can. So when we got a deer, which I mean, you could
literally just step off our deck and chew the deer literally. And we would, we'd butcher it up
and can it. So I found that canned meat is the best. It's just absolutely the best because it's just
tender. You could even take a pork cut and meat and pressure can it. And you just have the best,
you know, beef stroganoff or medicine stroganoff in the world. So we got into doing that
homestead stuff back before it was cool. In this generation, there's a lot of people doing it,
which is really, really exciting. But we've done that, you know, for back in the 90s when we lived
up in the woods.